Oh
writing the babymaker feeling like your
hair is perfect
[Music]
can't move
[Music]
Oh what the hell he's having fun is he
[Music]
well I'm glad someone is enjoying the
apocalypse okay well I guess you can't
go here then they just like it like yeah
that's pretty hot
that's one [ __ ] final Afeni I have it
[Music]
instead of cold father Christmas now
gives the bad children the kid is okay
and you're a stator Ned but Jack I'm so
sorry about what she says that I'm so
sorry about your boyfriend
was it his boyfriend no diving
you can't tell me what did you well [ __ ]
[Music]
you jab bloody head in the back that
plant you scared the [ __ ] out of me come
back go back what the [ __ ] are you doing
please I'm not even clicking anything
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you look
what you're doing you're not calm man
this is not how you make tea pants have
arrived I trust you
adventurer Bob surprise ball is out of
it
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
oh man you got quite the muscle lady Wow
[Music]
you know I exercise myself look I can't
do this anymore outside should not film
this this became way more awkward
oh my brain I'm scarred forever so very
bad place was really dirty let's go in
take a shower
how do I complete missions I don't
really understand what I'm doing -
[ __ ] neck man he thought I was a goat
no must make it does come with the cost
of looking like a bit stage but hey you
want a straight face you you got a
sacrifice the best you ever made
[Music]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] games let's get to ten baby
let's get you [ __ ] dad
[Music]
Steve whoa whoa this is actually cool
well don't you dare attack me well that
was the price still twerking now this
smells like your mama mama mia pizzeria
smelling the baby space it's okay I
guess
why were you here like that what's wrong
with my [ __ ] a cater Pilar and can
you tell can't everyone you're right I
can't believe I being so blind
everyone can teleport oh my god this way
we can continue listening to our
favorite song
[ __ ] ain't [ __ ] but hoes and tricks
lick on these nuts and suck the dick get
the [ __ ] out after you're gone and hop
into my ride and make a quick run hope
you enjoyed this montage if you did go
ahead and leave a like it helps me out a
lot I'm really glad you've Laura's like
the last one so I wanted to make a bonus
one for you this is the clips that
didn't make it into the other montage
thank you bros for subscribing and for
being a bro you ready for this you got
to do it bye